how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
everything relating to the MCU today we
have some very interesting news about
spider-man
now of course spider-man gave us all a
scare last summer when we didn't know if
he was going to remain in the MCU or not
now fortunately for us
he's remaining in the MCU for at least
two more films but over the weekend
we've heard some reports that say
spider-man may be in the MCU for good
which of course is what everybody wants
we also have a little bit more
information about that spider-man 2099
Disney Plus show that has been rumored
so we'll break down this report in this
video but first big congratulations to
Anthony Raffin who won last week's
giveaway
Anthony be sure to email me in the email
in my about Me section and we'll get you
your Funko pop since we're talking about
spider-man this week we're giving away a
Spider Man Funko pop the rules are the
same all you have to do is be subscribed
to the channel like the video and leave
a comment about the video down below so
over the weekend this report about
spider-man was posted on the YouTube
channel superhero buzz this was an
exclusive report given by Mikey Sutton
who gave us all the details about
spider-man
staying in the MCU last summer when all
of the Sony Marvel deal was going on
according to Mikey the spider-man rights
could be reverting back to Marvel
Studios and Disney now last summer
Marvel and Sony went through their
renegotiations of spider-man in the MCU
however according to Mikey they never
really planned on taking spider-man out
of the MCU it just doesn't make much
business sense for either party to not
allow spider-man to be in the MCU since
spider-man far from home was such a
massive success it was the first
spider-man movie to earn a billion
dollars at the box office
so it's a huge win-win for both Sony and
Marvel and Disney and Mikey says that
any animosity between Sony and Disney is
now put aside and the two companies are
working very very well with each other
and an example of this is the Morbius
trailer there were some big connections
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
spider-man in the Morbius trailer of
course we have the connection to
spider-man far from home where we saw
the picture of spider-man on the wall
and over it it said murderer which is
obviously referring to the post-credits
scene of spider-man far from home where
Mysterio revealed spider-man's identity
as Peter Parker and he also framed him
as
a murderer and then of course we have
Michael Keaton's character vulture
appearing and talking to Morbius as well
who of course was in spider-man
homecoming so right now the studios are
playing well with each other and
currently there are no plans to have
spider-man exit the MCU at any point in
time even after the next two spider-man
films the two studios are playing so
well with each other that he says that
he has indeed heard that the studios are
still planning a spider-man spin-off
series for Disney Plus and that he hears
that it's still looking to be spider-man
2099 and we've actually had more proof
that the studio's are playing well with
each other
Gina price bifid who has recently signed
on to direct Sony silver and black film
which was going to star silver sable and
black cat recently told us in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
that Disney Plus was an option for them
now the project has been scrapped so
don't expect a movie or a Disney Plus
show but the main point to take away
from this is this was a property that
was very similar to spider-man it was a
Marvel sony project that was supposed to
exist within Sony's spider-verse but
Marvel Studios and Disney said that they
could make a Disney Plus show out of it
this is another sign that the studios
are playing incredibly well with each
other right now both realize that
spider-man is a big part of the MCU and
is an incredible moneymaker for them
both and it's a win-win if he stays
inside the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
this is why we could get a spider-man
2099 show on Disney Plus both studios
know that everybody loves spider-man and
are looking for more spin-offs in fact
it was recently revealed that Marvel and
Sony have another project coming and of
course it's another spin-off of
spider-man highly believed to be a madam
web project again more evidence that the
studios are playing very well with each
other
and according to Mikey he still has been
hearing some things that say Sony still
could be bought although many parties
have denied that Sony Pictures is
willing to sell Mikey says that it is
still a possibility that Amazon or Apple
could buy them and if that were the case
the rights to spider-man would revert
back to Marvel Studios so that's a
possibility but right now we're very
grateful that Sony Pictures and Marvel
Studios are playing nice which means
that spider-man is likely going to stay
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe for a
very long time and we're
going to get other spider-man spin-off
series and projects as well so let me
know what you think about this let me
know how excited you are that will most
likely have spider-man in the MCU for a
very long time leave your thoughts in
the comments down below and don't forget
to like this video and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU for live updates you
can follow me on Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof